hallo liebe zuschauer es ist januar in
berlin und wie so oft im januar ist das
wetter wirklich beschissen
doch einer von uns wird heute rausgehen
müssen und eine neue episode für euch
machen
ratet mal wer du dass ich schon
angezogen bin das ist gut ja muss dann
gehen wir los los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
scheiß wetter
wie gefällt ihnen heute das wetter sehr
schlecht
kalt nass und matschig gut nicht so gut
nicht so schön ich ungemütlich
es stört mich nicht wie gefällt ihnen
heute das wetter und das wetter heute
gefällt mir das wird nicht so gut ist
schön bin ich auch jetzt kalt aber schön
ganz schlecht
wie gefällt dir das wetter
[Musik]
ich finde berlin hat auch sehr viele
schöne tage
und ja das mag auch kalt sein im winter
und sehr windig aber dafür gibt es so
viel angeboten was kann man in berlin
unternehmen dagegen im sommer denken
ein schönes machen kaffee trinken
spazieren gehen sie wieder nach hause
man kann filmen geht man kann essen
gehen ins kino
also vielleicht würde ich in einen
kaffee trinken oder ein paar museum
besuchen ja einfach etwas drinnen machen
was könnte man unternehmen heute in
berlin um dem wetter zu entrinnen museum
zum beispiel in die in die bar zum
beispiel in ein café ins schwimmbad hier
um die ecke ins kino auch hat viele
schöne kinos was man überall machen
können man kann fernsehen zum beispiel
drin museen gibt es ganz viele in berlin
das ist vielleicht eine möglichkeit
waren wie sie schon ihn ein ja in
mehreren zum beispiel jüdischen museum
zeigt ja was machen sie tatsächlich
heute
wir wollten jetzt in diesen buchladen
und danach in der bar und dann zurück
ins bett
wir singen gerade wir suchen gerade ein
bisschen vor uns hin
ja das ist das machen wir gerade welche
richtung welche richtung einfach nur so
bisschen erfundene melodie war dass
gerade bei mir improvisierte am besten
geben der ausstellungen oder flat ins
kino
was haben sie heute wohl nichts das ist
eine sehr gute lösung
[Musik]
was kann man in berlin unternehmen um
diese wetter zu entkommen
ganz viele schöne cafés gehen ja wie ich
finde gerade zu besuch und einfach ein
café lachen anderen trinken was haben
sie vor heute trinkt nicht ja genau und
später mit freunden essen gehen genau
also wir müssen eine freundin von mir
begegnen
ich habe sie letztes jahr in berlin
getroffen kennengelernt und wir werden
auch kaffee trinken ja eigentlich aber
man könnte schwimmen gehen es gibt ein
schönes schwimmbad ihren schwimmbad was
machen sie denn wir gehen nachher noch
in gstaad oder in die ins zentrum und
schauen uns ein paar sachen haben okay
und ausnahmsweise vielleicht schwimmbad
ähnliches sie weder rechtlich war
geschlagen hatte ich kann sagen was wir
gestern gemacht haben ich habe sie zu
opa genommen zum staatsoper unter den
linden und da ist wirklich sehr schön
weil das so einen alten gebäude mit
ziemlich viel geschichte und sportliche
sachen vielleicht bouldern gebäude ganz
gerne also kletterhallen gibt es schon
auch super viele was wollen wir zuletzt
klettern
sauer ist auch immer gut das schwimmen
wir haben hier ein schwimmbad in dem
hotel oder war es ist noch gar nicht so
lange offen bleiben man kann laufen
gehen fußballspielen gehen basketball
spielen gehen
fahrradfahren schwimmen yoga meditation
man kann doch nicht alles machen
irgendwann ihn auf jeden fall vertreibt
alle allen kummer und sorgen ja auf ihn
zählen sie etwas machen sie das genauso
machen beide yoga und es hilft auf jeden
fall
das ist sozusagen so eine kletterhalle
die nicht so als wenn man ist halt nicht
so hoch so dass man ohne sicherung
lettern kann es halt so niedriger ein
bisschen mehr
also es gibt ja unterschiedliche yoga
stieler und je nachdem ob man eher was
braucht für entspannung oder etwas
braucht um sich auszupowern sucht man
sich halt dann bring you gasthaus
deswegen das ist ja das besondere an dem
sport dass man gleich beides hat er
finden wir zumindest davon es geht ganz
viel über drüber mentalität also über
das mentale geht ganz viel halt und dann
schafft man einige dinge die man sonst
nicht geschafft hätte zum beispiel
sich mehr zu denen und so weiter
[Musik]
ja ja nie was denn da draußen ja es war
nass es war matschig es war kalt es war
windig aber die menschen waren super
freundlich du hast gesehen wie sie gegen
das wetter an gekämpft haben und
trotzdem hat hier da schon einen plan
gehabt wie er den tag verbringt damit
trotz des schlechten wetters die zeit
gut ist wieso liegst du eigentlich immer
mit klamotten im bett immer bereit
und jetzt müsst ihr bereit seien um euer
deutsch zu verbessern das könnten die
vier machen wenn ihr ein mitglied von
easy thermen werdet ihr bekommt jede
woche von uns interaktive übungen zu der
grammatik und den vokabeln von unseren
neuen episoden und zwar bei patchen
dazu laden wir euch herzlich ein ihr
könnt dort ein mitglied werden außerdem
könnt ihr uns bei instagram folgen und
ihr könnt uns abonnieren aldi links gibt
es hier und hier unten
danke fürs zu sehen und bis nächste
woche